foreign
[Music]
space is getting exciting again
[Music]
and they play for their country but
they're not allowed to wear this shirt
why everyone dreams of having your name
on the back of England shirt doesn't
matter walking out to a crowd
[Music]
hello hey there this is FYI and it's all
here for your info it's been a couple of
weeks since Braden was at Downing Street
finding out that our new prime minister
Liz truss and we wanted to check out the
situation
so you know that because of the pandemic
in the Ukraine war there's been less
food ingredients oil gas and other
supplies right yeah and because there's
less the prices have been going up well
that's the cost of living for you
the Prime Minister promised help for our
parents to pay for the bigger gas and
electricity bills they'll get and that's
what she's done by putting a limit on
what can be charged but what surprised
people was that the government also said
that the richest people would have to
pay less tax a single higher rate of
income tax of 40 percent taxes pay for
things like hospitals and the police but
if the government collect less tax they
have to borrow money even people in the
conservative party thought this was a
bad idea so after just a few days they
changed their mind
but what would labor do if they were in
charge this is Kia stammer he's the
leader of the opposition every year each
political party meets up to discuss the
best way to run the country Kia stama
was in Liverpool and Liz truss was in
Birmingham but who had the better ideas
we asked you to have your Shout
I stand here today as the first prime
minister of our country to have gone to
a comprehensive school the only way to
stop this is with a labor government I
think case time I taught convincingly he
knew like what he was talking about my
message for all is trust would probably
be um whatever you do can affect
everyone or a lot of people I have three
priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth I'm so proud to launch
our green Prosperity plan when I'm old
enough I would work yesterday because
like he's saying that he will go to
NetZero at 20 30. 100 clean Power by
2030. let's trust is saying that she'll
go to NetZero at 2015. but do you think
they're actually going to do it by 2030
well Liz trust said oh we will produce
more of oil and gas but she did say that
she's gonna reduce the tax price yeah
but what that does that do with the
environment I believe that you know best
how to spend your own money she's
planning on lowering taxes for the rich
it would probably have devastating
impacts because there's less taxes to
run at the NHS well I've heard she has
kind of messed up the economies there's
lots of panic as a father I'm spurred on
by the voices of our children I think
Kirsten he seems like a good speaker in
front of
people some premises are like helping
the people I think so they should focus
on more like helping the younger
Generations
[Music]
thanks to everyone at sawston Village
College if you want to get some friends
together and talk about what matters to
you you could start an FYI News Club all
the details are on our website
and if you're in a News Club you'll know
that not every story you see is true so
you'll like this
[Music]
last week hurricane Ian devastated parts
of America and people even lost their
lives
but the coastal Waters also swept in
some unusual sightings
massive elephant seal went viral after
reports that after Hurricane Ian reached
land it was stranded on a street in
Florida is it fake news or fact we'll
give you the answer later
[Music]
the devastating storm hurricane Ian was
also responsible for the delay of the
launch of Artemis 1. the test flight was
due to blast off from Kennedy Space
Center in Florida but the rock actor
returned to the Vehicle Assembly
Building when the storm was forecast it
now means it's been canceled three times
Artemis is the next step in America
Space Program to return to the moon the
mission will test how much rocket power
is needed to get there
such a shame it was canceled I know it
was way back in 1969 over 50 years ago
when Neil Armstrong was the first man on
the moon with the famous words
but there hasn't been a woman on the
moon yet the good news is this week
things have got going this is an Artemis
it's the fifth SpaceX mission to take
astronauts to the International Space
Station and that did go into space this
week I love watching the launch
four three two one
whoa that's amazing that's so cool
before they blasted off I checked in
with NASA to see if they were ready the
only problem was the time difference
it's Scarlett from FYI on Sky News and
sky kids wait you spoke to NASA of
course I did at the launch Readiness
review I found out more about Nicole
Mann this week she became NASA's first
female Mission Commander
how will Mission Commander Nicole Mann's
time in space help NASA Return To The
Moon good question Scarlett the crew
members Nicole specifically will be
doing experiments on some of the life
support systems that we need to improve
on that we are going to need to go back
to the moon and then eventually to Mars
a big moment for Nicole of course as
it's her first time in space
and get this the man in charge of the
International Space Station also had a
tip for me
now finish and say do your homework
every day and maybe we'll be talking to
you one day from space thank you Joel
and this was the last press briefing
from NASA before the launch day that's
so cool I know well Nicole and the rest
of her crew docked safely on Thursday
and Nicole will be doing her research in
space for six months
it's been a good time for NASA in
distant space too you've heard of
asteroids right check this out
they're not planets they're actually
bits of rock orbiting in space and when
a really big one comes along there can
be a bit of bump to put it mildly
scientists think that the last one made
the dinosaurs extinct
now obviously they didn't have video
back then but it might have looked
something like this I can see why we'd
want to avoid that happening it's very
very very unlikely to happen but to
protect our planet NASA still wanted to
test the technology to divert an
asteroid if they ever have to
so they built the dart probe and sent it
into space to hunt out an asteroid
called diamorphos This is the most
expensive crash in the history of the
universe so it's getting closer closer
closer well I mean it must have worked
they look very happy
telescopes will have to confirm it did
its job finally there was a space world
record last week well kind of it was the
first weightless football match this
team went on what's called a parabolic
flight you go so high up into the
Earth's atmosphere that for a few
seconds in free fall you become
absolutely weightless that's so cool
check it out it looks like so much fun
playing football
astronauts do it for training and so
this lot got in the record books by
being weightless for a few seconds just
like in space
[Music]
sick of your dad filming your school
concert badly is it worse than this Dad
Andrew and his friends were on a tvob
outside broadcasting truck take a look
[Music]
Sam Andrew and this is e2e outside
broadcasting unit on these four wheels
you could expect the same type of
equipment you find in a studio we just
rock up
[Music]
we are filming here a year seven concert
up to year nines
let me introduce you to the crew
here we have the Isla on camera and over
there we have James on camera and we
have Jack here on camera each camera is
positioned in a different place so we
have a choice of angles on the concert
they're all connected to over mission
control that's where I come in I'm
directing for the first hour and then
Isla's gonna direct for the second hour
I will be inside on one of the cameras
trying to do that widening close-up
shots in a wide shot you can see
everyone in a close-up you zoom into the
action so I am the vision mixer and what
I do is I change what camera angles go
on to the live to make the video or the
live stream more interesting it looks
easy doesn't it but this is live the
audience is arriving and we only have
one chance to capture this action the
pressure is on
it's camera one
it is quite
quality but I like having responsibility
are we on camera one yeah so what I
enjoy is that I get to work with all my
friends and I'm about to go as a team
other people they like football or
something but I like what I'm doing
right now camera to your live cut camera
one
and the show's over we made it I feel
like it went amazing really we got some
really good shots and they played really
well I think we've got brilliant shots
and I think it'll look good on the
recording
[Music]
check these guys out Catalonia in Spain
has this weird tradition for over 200
years people have been forming human
towers and competing to build the
highest and most complicated Tower
awesome just remember don't do this at
home
[Applause]
foreign
says that the football World Cup starts
this week and England are playing in
Turkey are you sure I thought it didn't
start until November well that's what
Braden says just when you think you've
seen everything football has to offer
today I'm playing with a team like no
other
[Music]
yeah
football isn't just a sport assume it's
how you identify yourself it can give
you confidence Fitness and a sense of
belonging
this is the amputee football squad
I'm Thomas Atkinson I'm an 18 year old
and I'm a goalkeeper thing with NPCs 18
in the captain as well oh yeah
but I always pray and fall off my leg
and then as soon as I kick the football
again just like that's it when you lose
a leg no matter what was the reason
about it you always think that you're
not going to be able to to play it again
but they also left footed before I lost
my leg so I had to re-adapt and learn
how to pass out the Sheep this is all
been all my life so that's all I've ever
knew so this is like my everyday
though it's called amputee football to
Thomas and his team it's just football
it's team England they know they're the
best in the country now they're about to
find out whether they're the best in the
world and I've come just in time
this is their final training camp before
they fly out to Turkey to hopefully have
their chance to reach the final in the
world cup so far they've played against
USA Argentina and Indonesia
but it's quite a new sport there's one
thing that we can't do yet
playing for your country is always meant
having three lines on your shirt it's a
tradition that goes back to the famous
year of 1966 when England won the World
Cup at Wembley
kill him well the three lines logo is a
trademark that means it belongs to the
English Football Association his amputee
football takes off in England their
players hope that they might get
permission to use it
everyone's dreams of having your name on
the back of England shirt doesn't
they're walking out to a crowd just
being able to be under the same bracket
as the England team
um it should be special for us all from
what I've seen these guys play just as
if not better than any other team
come on
so if you could win any trophy what
would you win
it's got to be the World Cup it's got to
be the World Cup well this week is
Thomas's big chance come on England bang
them goals in
we spoke to the Football Association and
they said we are looking at potential
opportunities which could lead to the
integration of the England amputee teams
with the fa and I've got Thomas on the
phone live from Turkey so Thomas how's
it going hi uh you're speaking to me a
couple hours after we've just lost one
nil to Angola oh that's devastating
obviously we weren't at the level that
we needed to be to be um the world
champions yeah well you've done so well
to get this far I mean I can't stop the
lads we did incredible well better luck
next time and hopefully one day you'll
be able to play with the three lines on
your shirt oh yeah that's the plan
[Music]
earlier we told you that after Hurricane
Ian there have been reports of animals
swept into the street but was the one we
told you about an elephant seal fake
news or facts
it was fake
seal was certainly lost but not after
Hurricane Ian
fake news can happen when people share
something without checking their facts
the original video has been around for
two years we've even shown it on FYI and
that's not Florida it's a town in Chile
[Music]
I got it right well that's it for this
week's FYI but we'll leave you with some
cool shots of Nicole man and the rest of
her crew enjoying their first moments in
space together bye
and here we've come through first one
through the hatch is going to be Nicole
Mann commander of dragon and now the
first Native American woman to live and
stay aboard the International Space
Station
[Music]